la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'Europe alimente encore une fois les
graines de catastrophe les attaques
s'intensifient déjà ciblées par des tirs
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique mais en garde contre un risque
de grave accident nucléaire la situation
serait potentiellement dangereuse autour
du titre c'est dans un secteur un
contrôler par les Russes
je crois qu'il y a une inquiétude de
tout à fait justifiée à l'idée que des
combats pourraient avoir lieu dans 18
villes à proximité l'évacuation
temporaire a été ordonnée par les
autorités russes des milliers d'auto
sont massés et doivent attendre
plusieurs heures au poste de contrôle
les civils se précipitent pour quitter
la région qui pourrait devenir le
théâtre d'intense bataille
côté russe la tension augmente aussi les
forces ukrainiennes ont lancé des
attaques contre la ville de Belgorod un
gazodieux qui est des lignes électriques
ont notamment été endommagés
entendre le contraire faute de soutien
pour combattre l'armée ukrainienne le
chef menacé d'y retirer ses troupes il
s'est finalement vu promettre autant
d'armes et de munitions que nécessaire
par Moscou
la contre-offensive ukrainienne attendue
ce printemps elle serait imminente
surprenant que le jour J est déjà été
décidé et si c'était le cas nous
pourrions être un j-8 ou à J-10 et elle
pourrait bien se jouer à zapporigia ici
aimez le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal